Ladies and gentlemen,
Adam Carolla's here.
Did you do too much?
Shit,
I do too much shit.
But you do too much shit compared to the shit that I do.
You did just did a fucking movie.
How do you have time to do a movie?
You do 85 podcasts.
He'd do a TV show on spike,
got a family grown a beard,
drive cars.
The beards.
Easiest part.
But keep going.
Tell you what's in pubes.
Do standup comedy.
You do a lot of podcasts.
Yes.
What the fuck dude?
Well I,
you know,
I,
I I,
you know,
a couple of things I started realized like after I had my twins that what I did
was radio podcasting,
but I felt like it was all just floating up into the ether,
you know,
and I thought I want some sort of permanent record,
like some sort of legacy,
you know,
books,
movies,
the stuff that gets passed around.
You know,
what I'm saying is,
is over Christmas time,
me and my eight year old twins,
we watched planes,
trains,
and automobiles and loved the shit out of it.
And that movies like 30 years old now.
Great.
It's great fucking movie,
but you want to feel old.
It's like how long has John Candy Been Dead?
Like six years now.
15 years or 20 years like,
but the point is is that thing and John Hughes too,
so they didn't,
we weren't listening to you know,
ass crack and backsack in the morning from 1984 we were watching a movie for
that era and I just sort of had this feeling at a certain point like yeah,
I like doing the podcast.
I liked doing radio and TV shows and stuff like that,
but doing a movie for some reason,
those are the ones that get passed on versus the podcast and look,
I'm sure someone long after will be,
we're gone or going to be listening to our archives,
but not what the rate year olds,
right?
No,
definitely not.
What they're eight year olds and they might be listening to our archives or our
archives might all be lost out in the ether.
That's possible too.
That's,
that's kind of what I felt like all I ever did was talk and all it ever did was
just float up and just go up into the,
into the atmosphere and blow away maybe maybe into Canada and caused them acid
rain.
So that was really your,
your motivation was just a leaves,
a solid legacy.
Who's this?
Like I,
I read,
it was,
it was two things for me and movies.
It was a whole bunch of people sort of saying,
well you,
you can't do movies.
You do radio and the radio guy or you know,
you can't do this just for me.
Not,
not,
not saying you can't,
but not being taken seriously.
Like you can go do this.
And then the other thing is like I had an idea for a movie,
which I don't have that often,
but what I want to have an idea,
I want to execute the idea.
Right.
You probably wired that way.
Yeah.
Once I have,
it's almost like a,
yeah,
you get like a seed is growing.
It starts poking out through the dirt and you're like,
all right,
we got to do something here.
This is,
this is moving.
Right.
So I made a movie called the hammer like eight years ago and I didn't make any
more movies.
And then I had this idea like two years ago and I was like,
let's,
let's do it.
And the hammer was about a boxer,
right?
He had the hammer was about a boxer and this is more about a road hard is more
about just comedians and the road and getting old and how the road is getting
old for a lot of these guys.
Cause I started seeing all these guys passing through my studio.
Like you see him to write and they're like going,
hey,
it's going to be down at hilarity.
And Addison,
Texas,
that's one show.
And then to Friday to Saturday.
And then he'd go like,
yeah,
I got to blow in a day early to do local radio.
I need you think to yourself,
God,
I used to watch that guy on in living color.
I used to watch that guy on a sitcom or something and now he's back on the road
and I know he ain't happy about it,
but he's on the road and I just kind of wanted to tell that story about taking a
step backward in life.
So this is a story is about a guy who was a sitcom actor who has to do standup
again to make a living,
got divorced,
work dried up.
It all became reality shows,
you know,
he used to remember that holding deals,
development deals free money if they don't exist anymore,
right?
No,
those deals,
you know those deals.
I mean they took all,
you know,
soon as Roseanne and Seinfeld and Tim Allen and Ray Romano had success doing
sitcoms.
Hollywood was like,
who's the next Ray Romano going to be?
And so they started bringing guys in and throw in tons of cash,
Adam just to spit ball ideas and just whatever.
And there was a lot of God.
And so the guys who immediately got off the road because they're like,
screw that,
I'm moving to Hollywood.
And some of them had some success.
Some of them had some difficulties in marriage rehab,
things like that.
The point is is now they're all knocking on the door,
50 divorced and ready to hit the road.
Again.
They don't want to hit the road,
but how else are you going to make a living?
It's all reality.
It's all reality show.
Interesting.
So this guy,
this idea got in your head because of dealing with all these people that come
into your studio?
No.
I mean yes it was snowing combination.
No,
I started seeing like you know that thought where the guys explaining the club
he's going to and you're like,
I know that club and then you start,
your next thought is that's kind of a,
that's kind of a shitty club.
And then you think,
wait a minute,
this guy kind of a name.
Like this guy's a little bit of a household name.
Why is he playing that Shitty club?
And then you start feeling sort of bad for him,
even though you shouldn't cause Roofer,
cop,
fireman,
all all real jobs versus going to hilarides and getting paid for,
you know,
standing up on stage and holding a beer in your hand.
But you're feeling bad for this guy because you know,
he doesn't really want to go there.
And you know,
he has other friends.
You know,
I'd have David Allen Greer say,
I got to go to Addison,
Texas and I know Jamie Foxx doesn't have to go to Addison,
Texas raw.
And at some point he was probably telling Jamie Foxx,
here's how comedy works,
rather sit down.
You know what I mean?
So yeah,
it was,
it was telling the story of stepping backwards and,
and for me,
uh,
you know,
I had to live it myself.
I live that story in my,
you know,
about,
uh,
when in 2009 when I got fired from my radio job,
there were no jobs and there's no,
there was no radio jobs and there was no television jobs,
far as I could tell.
I mean,
like the phone wasn't ringing.
And,
uh,
the only way,
and I had young twins and I just had to hit the road and I didn't have an act.
All I had was Adam Carolla's coming to your town and that was good enough to
sell a few tickets and I was just coming to your town and I just told the
booker,
you know,
wherever,
whenever,
how many shows,
it doesn't matter.
I'm there.
Wow.
And I spent a year being like humbled,
you know,
six years ago.
That's not very long ago.
No,
it's not that long ago.
And it was a lot of southwest flights and red roof inns and a lot of like,
I didn't know the road so I didn't know about what you get an opener so you
don't have to do a full 90 minutes set or whatever.
I was doing three 95 minutes sets in a row by yourself,
just find myself.
You're doing three shows on Friday,
like that kind of deal.
It's three shows on Saturday.
When when I,
when I started a really like started to crack
is uh,
we did,
we are,
our gig was,
we're a book a night at cop Thursday,
Thursday night at cobb's in San Francisco.
It's a pretty good sized club.
So Thursday night,
you know,
it's like I don't 500 seats or something.
So it's a Thursday night.
We'll do a show in cobb's,
then we'll go to Kirkland,
Washington and we'll do two shows Friday,
two shows Saturday.
I said,
all right,
so I get the call.
The first show was sold out.
You want to add a second show,
second show added,
sold out.
You want to add a third show.
Now I know that third shows going to be miserable,
but I'm only going to San Francisco to try to get some money and bring it back.
And the nicer of the flight and the nicer the hotel,
the less money that comes back.
And I used to say to someone,
look,
I'm just going to wake up Friday morning in San Francisco one way or the other.
If I do one show,
two shows or three shows at some point I'm going to wake up that next day and
I'll just be in a hotel bed.
Maya's we'll have an extra whatever amount of grand in my pocket.
Right?
So just go for it.
So I did it.
And then the same thing happened in Kirkland,
Washington,
three shows for a show,
second show,
third year they all sold out.
So they kept adding them.
And before you knew it I was like disoriented,
like up on stage and I thought 90 minutes,
what's the minimum amount I could do?
So I do like 95 a hundred minutes of show and I didn't know about the opener or
the local guy or the anything.
So never brought anybody with you at all?
No.
See that.
That's that.
That the problem with the road would,
when you do that,
it gets really lonely.
It gets weird.
I always had Mike August with me who was,
who was booking all this stuff and was,
you know,
it was fun to see him in the green room eating every time to see what he ate.
You know,
I just,
the remnants of what he ordered,
like I'm set the Matsu Mozzarella sticks or the chicken fingers,
Mike.
I got them both.
He'd just be watching college football the whole time on the sofa.
That's way too big for the room that it's in.
Right.
And,
but we just went for it.
Like that was it.
So I got this weird crash course on the road,
you know,
at age 43 or 44 and I was like,
wow,
man,
this is rough.
I mean,
it would've been cool at 27.
Yeah.
Single and whatnot.
Well,
it's also,
you didn't have an act,
so you just have an app ideas that you would just talk about on stage for 90
minutes.
Um,
how did it go?
It went,
went surprisingly well.
They're happy to see you.
They're happy to see me,
but that's,
that's not going to last 95 minutes.
You had some ideas.
He must've had some stuff do you were planning on talking about when you got up
there?
What I would do is I would the first like hour or 45 minutes or something would
just be,
what can Adam complain about it and people just shout out shit from the audience
and I would have to riff on it,
but it would be kind of a calorie burner because I have to,
you know,
come up with this material and then my head would start swimming.
Like,
did I do this already?
I couldn't remember if I did it in first.
The guy yelled out kittens that he yelled at in this show or is that the third
show or the second show?
Like start floating a little up there.
Um,
but eventually
what I would do is you,
you know,
I'd walk through Kirkland,
Washington and I'd see,
oh,
they have little flags that they use that go into a little receptacle.
And when they,
when you cross the street,
even at a signal and the crosswalk,
you hold the little flag up and then you go set it back down.
And the receptacle on the other side of the street,
everyone,
Washington,
well,
they provide them for everybody that you have to have a flag to cross the
street.
You're not going to get penalized by it.
It's just a courtesy that the town of Kirkland,
Washington offers.
What's the benefit of the flag?
You not being run over?
Well,
they don't see you if you don't have a flag or they've,
you're more visible.
Well,
what the Fuck Joe Rogan Fuck is wrong with your eyesight up in Kirkland wa how
cloudy is it up there?
I haven't saying however visible visible Joe Rogan is,
he's at least 35% more visible with an orange flag over his head.
Wow.
Yeah.
How bizarre.
Well prompted that.
I don't know,
but there's my first 15 minutes.
Oh yeah,
I could see you going on for an hour about that.
Yeah.
So I would blow into every town and just,
you'll look around with a buck slip and go like flag window.
So we're there.
Okay.
What's going on?
And by the half of it was,
oh,
the last lascon airline flight out here,
blah,
blah blah.
You know,
just anything,
just anything.
And then once I hit the stage,
I could,
I could riff on it.
But after,
you know,
obviously after,
uh,
what,
what started happening is then,
you know,
next week in Phoenix,
I'd go a,
you guys got a nice town,
but let me tell you about Kirkland,
Washington.
They got flax to cross,
you know,
and then I could do the same 10 minutes again.
And that's the how the act was built during the course of the experience on the
road.
That there's a lot of guys who wind up doing that,
that,
uh,
are Sitcom actors that wound up doing stand up after they became a sitcom actor.
Like screech from saved by the bells,
particularly famous for it.
Well,
yeah,
it just got a name.
Yeah.
Danny Bonaduce wouldn't do an act like,
it's just like you don't have an act,
but you do have a currency.
The currencies,
we recognize your name on the marquee.
Uh,
so folks who weren't formally standups are now going to have to be fake standups
if and they want to eat.
Yeah.
Do you remember skippy from family ties?
Sure.
He used to do that skippy from family ties.
Like when I was first starting out,
he was hitting the road skippy though.
I mean to give the skippy is due.
He was,
he was doing it like when he was doing it or while she was gone.
He was even before or after.
I mean somebody can research this,
but I remember doing two things.
I remember doing an open mic at the Improv,
the Melrose improv about,
you know,
1985 maybe 1986 and skippy was there.
So it was,
it wasn't like,
oh that show got cancelled and now he's trying his hand at stand up like he was
banging away at it.
I also think the guy went up missing recently and maybe dead went out in like
the wilderness and like killed himself.
Someone's going to have to do some skippy research.
I think you might be confused and skippy with the guy who killed the a,
the development deal that we were talking about earlier,
it's chicken.
Do you know that story?
No.
You don't know what killed the development deal?
No,
they're the Montreal.
Specially the Montreal comedy festival was this big event where all the industry
would go there and it was really kind of an excuse to go drink and uh,
been there.
They would go and have a great time,
but they would hand out these development deals and some of them were pretty big
and a really big one was given to this guy that called himself chicken and
chicken would,
it was a young,
cute guy and he would go wacky on stage,
sort of Jim Carrey ask and the less aware of the industry,
like you know those people that you talk to and they're just kind of,
they're kind of like a metal filings getting pulled towards the magnet.
They don't necessarily have their own compass.
They don't necessarily have their own opinion on things that they formulated.
They might be young,
they might be impressionable,
but they kind of go with,
oh,
he's amazing.
He's so talented.
He's so good.
You should see his energy.
It's incredible.
And Ralph had had about a million people and then you meet the guy or you see
his act or you're whatever,
and you're like,
what am I missing?
This was that times a hundred this was that.
This was like every comic.
I mean,
every comic was like,
what the fuck?
Like you'll get comics that'll defend the most undependable,
you know what you mean?
There's a lot of comics that you know,
love,
all sorts of weird marginal acts,
but this guy was off the charts,
off the charts bad or off the charts bad,
but got a giant development deal,
like a half a million dollars and it just went south.
He came to Hollywood,
can act,
can't do anything.
Started bombing.
They realized like,
what did we do?
We gave a half million dollars to a crazy person and literally that was the end
of the development deal.
It just stopped with this one guy.
He wound up hanging himself in front of a school somewhere.
That's the,
the,
the urban myth.
Oh really?
I don't know.
Urban legend rather.
I'm not sure if that's actually exactly what happened.
I know he killed himself.
Somebody's going to have to,
well,
you know,
I was saying the other day,
I think second only to cops in suicide comedians might be,
might be number two in this suicide department.
I'd like to see the rest of the list.
How many comics do you know?
I know Richard.
Jenny,
who else?
Oh,
there's been,
well yeah,
I,
there's a,
I was just thinking of a hell is that just thinking of Robin Williams course.
Robin Williams.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think of what other profession that there's not as many,
there's a lot more cops than there are comedians.
I mean,
at least people you've heard of.
Right?
Probably a bunch of people that never made it,
that did it.
But now I've got to find out what happened is skippy.
Yeah,
Jamie.
We'll Google that skippy from family ties.
We'll see what happens.
Yeah.
So I had to go out and like just tough it out and it was like,
it sucked,
you know,
it was humbling,
you know?
It was,
it was,
it was interesting.
It was tiring.
It was a little depressing,
but it was like mostly scary and humbling.
Well if you got kids,
it's a tricky situation.
Like you've got a good work,
you got to get something done.
He actually did.
When you left your radio show on your radio show got canceled.
Did you have any sort of a severance package or,
yeah,
the good news,
the good news is I had until the end of the year,
so I had like nine and a half months to get paid,
but the clock was ticking and the phone wasn't ringing.
And so I was like,
I got to get out there and then at a certain point I just decided I need to take
this guy and tweak them a little bit and make him make him into a movie.
And so we did the crowd funding thing and raise the money that way and blah,
blah,
blah.
It turned out,
uh,
the movie's really good actually.
I'm trying to,
I thought I,
did I get it to you or not?
Yeah,
I just haven't had a chance to watch it.
I'll watch it this weekend though.
I'm going to Dallas.
Oh,
watch a hand road.
Yeah,
you're gonna.
You're gonna like it.
Yeah.
You recognize a lot of the people in it.
I've managed to stifle that sort of a boredom on the road.
One of the things I do is I always bring my friends.
I bring a really funny guys that opened for me and to,
uh,
I,
I'd mix it up a lot with the UFC.
Like I travel,
like this weekend I'm doing the majestic theater on Friday night in Dallas and
then Saturday night there's a big UFC event.
So for me it mixes things up.
I mean,
it's my family,
I missed my home,
but I like all the people that I work with.
I love working for the UFC.
I love doing standup.
So it's,
it's,
the road is not bad for me and I only do it for like a couple days.
I know guys who go out for like 20,
30 days in a row and you just come back and you're a shell.
You know,
you have to fucking drink orange juice for a month just to get your fucking Eei.
I don't lights back.
Yeah,
that's,
that's my whole thing is I've just go out for two days,
work really hard for like two days and then come back two,
three days.
I try to keep it to that with the family and podcasting and all that stuff.
But um,
and yeah,
variety and mixing it up.
That's,
that's,
that's the other key.
So now,
half the time,
Nah,
now I,
I,
for me it's like seven,
eight at the time I'm just doing a live podcast.
I brought you something.
Ooh,
those yours,
you recognize those reading glasses.
Do you recognize those?
No,
I don't.
You sure?
Yes.
I think you left those bitches at my house and like 2009,
uh,
I think Lisa Loeb left.
It's your house and 2009 no confused.
Sure.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
they worked for me.
It's weird.
I started using them,
but I'm pretty,
I,
it might be yours dude.
They don't work aesthetically for you,
but no,
they don't work aesthetically.
But what they do,
because I,
I liked things like fanny packs.
I like shit that doesn't work.
Aesthetic.
Oh my God,
I'm so glad I'm,
I'm looking to get that fanny pack going man.
Listen,
I've been bringing it back.
I sell them.
I have one for you.
Do we have one form?
Go get him one.
Don't real good one.
Don't dangle that pack in front of me unless,
unless I'm taking it home.
Taking it home,
sir.
I've got one for you.
It's leather.
It's a nice routes.
Fanny pack.
Very sturdy construction.
I don't travel without it.
I listen.
I just got back from the east coast and it was blue snow in New York.
Snow in the whole time.
Look at that.
Oh,
I'm pumped man.
Look at that.
And by the way,
this doesn't say,
you know,
a lot of fanny packs say not getting laid.
Definitely checking out some comic books on a,
on a Saturday night.
This says may have a gun
and I liked with,
I like with this is projecting to the world a little better than the average
fanny pack.
Wow.
I sold out of those three times.
This is nice.
If you go to higher primate.com I sell those.
It's got the higher primate logo in the pocket with a zipper in it.
But that's roots.
Wow.
It's really nice.
Well dice clay had one,
he came in and he's got the sweat pants.
I got the phone and I was like I'm so happy that you wear a fanny pack cause I
wear them all the time and people give me a hard time if you're not trying to
get laid,
it's really the way to go because like convenience wise a like you go to the
airport,
I unstrapped that sucker.
I drop it in that Bin and I'm done.
I'm not fishing in my pockets were coins.
I just made the proclamation because I just got back from the east coast where
there was a blizzard going on and in New York I said it's so nice wearing a big
jacket with the inside pockets and the flaps and the things like finally I can
put my cell phone and my wallet somewhere cause I'm so tired of the t shirt and
the jeans out here.
Whether you're always sitting on your phone and whatnot.
Like I was,
I was happy just to be wearing the big Parker that had all the,
all the,
all the pockets in it,
but that wouldn't work around La.
They think you're homeless freak.
So now I'm going fanny pack.
Yeah,
they love it.
I love it.
I'm a big fan.
It's just,
it became one of those things that got mocked and guys just abandoned it because
they didn't want to look like losers.
But I say,
fuck that.
No,
but this,
but hold on a second.
This is like a lot more Holtz.
Their holster than it is fanny pack.
I wouldn't be,
I wouldn't even classify this.
I wouldn't call this a fanny pack roots sells.
It routes the luggage company from Canada,
they don't call it a fanny pack.
They call it like a waste bag or something.
Fucking stupid.
Which is,
you know,
yeah,
yeah.
But there's a,
there's a negative connotation to fanny pack.
Not In my world.
All right,
well not with that bed.
I'm excited.
So dice clay came in with one of those on and I saw that.
I'm like,
that is a pretty good damn sweet fanny pack and a,
he's like,
yeah,
I love these.
I love them.
I'm women,
I'm all the time.
Oh.
So I uh,
I uh,
contacted roots and had them make one with my logo on it.
I was thinking about dice the other day.
I was thinking who invented him smoking the cigarette from around the backs of
the round rock wrong side of his head.
And then how did that work?
And then who decided that was part of the comedy like this,
it's a weird thing to do.
Like it's like I,
it's a way to stave off lung cancer cause it's like I can barely can't quite,
or if I get too fat I can't smoke because I can't get my hand around my back of
my neck areas.
Oh,
well he got to a point I think where he was kind of mocking himself.
Was that it?
You know,
that was a character,
but the dental that right?
Yeah.
No,
I've,
I've talked to the guy quite a bit about it.
No,
he's really just an actor.
Well see people don't,
his name is Andrew Silverstein and this dice character was one of several
characters that he does.
He did in his act,
he's do John Travolta,
he's do Sylvester Stallone.
When he would do this dice man and the dice man became easily the most popular
part of his Zach.
So then he kind of morphed into being in him and then like everywhere he goes
would dress like the dice man.
Well it's,
it's this weird trap Larry the cable guy stand up.
It wasn't,
yeah,
getting any traction just became this guy on the radio and Tampa or something.
And next thing you know the club would rather book Larry the cable guy and Dan
Whitney.
Then Dan Whitney.
So they go with Larry the cable guy.
I started off doing Mr Birch,
him the shop teacher out here.
And at a certain point when it came time to take over on Loveline k rock,
the mother station was like,
we'd like you to host love line is Mr Birch,
him the woodshop teacher.
And I was like,
how's that going to work?
And they were like,
well,
we know Mr Bertram is funny,
but we're not sure if you're funding,
which is a weird thing to say to the same guys doing both of them.
But I said,
if I do,
Mr Birch,
I'm,
I love line.
I'm going to blow my voice out,
but I'm also,
that's just not going to,
why would you pull your voice?
What was the care,
how'd it go?
Um,
Mr Birch them was a 60,
whatever year old Vietnam veteran who taught,
um,
he taught woodworking.
He taught remedial.
Would a Louie pass your middle school in Monrovia?
Yeah,
it's pretty specific.
Yeah.
And he hated his kids.
He,
he,
he hate,
he hated all his kids.
And he would,
every Monday he would call in to Kevin and being,
because he got into another accident in the garage,
you know,
with the band saw or something.
And he wasn't going to be making it in.
But so you'd say,
well,
why is this guy calling Kevin and being to tell him he's not coming in to do his
teachers shop class that day?
And what I had figured out is that all of his kids who tended to class,
cause it was junior high,
they all listened to k rock.
So he would use k rock is like his own PA system to speak to his kids like at
seven 30 in the morning cause they're all heading in and you know,
he'd be like,
uh,
um,
and I listen and I,
and I know you love all the,
the smashing dumplings and Nervosa and all that shit.
Got K rock plays,
uh,
that Quimby,
Mr [inaudible] Ponzi is going to be taken over for me today.
So here's the deal.
You're all going to show up.
We're going to put blood on the band saw on and then you put your head down and
nobody messes with my drill index.
Nobody messes with my Makita posers.
And then he'd get into like his one student that he liked because all assholes
shop teachers always overcompensate with the one kid and they're like their
total dickheads to 26 kids and super nice to one kid for some fucking reason.
Like Super Douche bags.
Starlets are super like an incredible with their dog,
you know,
and then super shitty with all the human beings around them.
Right.
It all gets channeled into the one terrier or something.
So He'd go,
he's one guy was a Brad Higgins staller and he's like,
Brad been thinking about that Kayak over the weekend.
Ah,
I don't want to go with a butt joint and I don't want to go with a date.
Oh,
I don't want to go the rabbit join.
Um,
let's,
you know,
let's go with a finger joint.
Oh no,
that's go that date.
I'll put the date.
Oh,
set up on the contractor Shaw,
you know,
and I just go through all the super specific,
whatever that I knew from home building.
And this guy became this like overnight sensation because they didn't know if Mr
Birch him was a real guy or not.
Cause he,
he make a lot of jokes,
but then he'd get super specific with Shit and nobody knew who he was.
So then he got so popular,
they wanted him to host love line.
But I was like this,
I ended up doing that show for a decade.
Yeah.
I couldn't do it as Mr Birch him.
So when you came in and you did it as Adam Corolla,
like,
was it like,
boy,
I don't know Adam,
do you think you could do a little Mister Bertram,
you think we can get to like half Mr Birch?
I'm half.
Adam can see you at them.
Could you say Adam and Mr Bertram,
could you go like Phil Hendrie style to both voices back and forth?
So we wearing a condom.
Hey,
what are you asking about his cock for?
Yeah.
Uh,
I just said,
look,
this is,
this is not going to work.
Big Picture.
Like I could do one episode this way,
but you don't want Mr Birch from two hours a night every night.
And uh,
plus we were just starting syndication.
So we're only in one city that kind of knew Mr Birch and then the rest of the
cities didn't know Mr Birch him.
So would,
it wouldn't have made sense.
You would have to start from scratch again.
I wouldn't want it to.
So we ended up in over a hundred city.
So that's probably probably best.
But yeah,
that's,
that's how it all,
that's how it all got started
when you started your podcast,
when you,
uh,
I did it like way,
way back in the day back when you were still sitting on that couch and you had
to clip on microphones,
you went through,
you went through all the different versions of how to set it up sort of the way
everybody kind of does.
Like my friend Steve Rinella,
he's got this great podcast now and he's doing it.
He's the host of the show meat eater.
He's a professional hunter and an author,
and they're doing a podcast now.
It's an amazing podcast,
but they have these headset microphones on,
so they got the,
the earphones and the microphone on it.
And every time someone moves it's clunky.
Yeah,
right.
It's fucking maddening.
And I'm like,
you can't have the headset,
Mike.
You've got to have us a Mike that just sits there.
Condenser mic.
Yeah.
The more people touch it,
the more it's going to suck for.
If you have ear buds on,
they gotta take my earbuds out.
I'm like,
this is,
I'm going to go crazy.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
God,
I remember a million years ago when I was doing Bill Simmons podcast from his
garage,
he was set up but like only set up with one microphone or that's all they could
do.
So I had to call into the show,
but I was there.
So I literally got his phone,
like his home phone and dialed in and then stood out in the driveway.
That's hilarious.
Well,
I couldn't call him through the room cause he'd hear me through the mic,
but fuck it.
Believed through the mic.
Kind of the Gardner started coming around with the leaf blower and it's like,
I'm calling it up,
you know,
no podcast.
Yeah,
no,
he didn't understand what a podcast was.
One did back then.
It was like standing out in his driveway talking on his,
not,
not even his cordless,
you know,
it's home phone.
Right.
Just the cordless one.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Everyone get some decent equipment,
please.
What year did you start?
Uh,
I started,
uh,
an oh nine,
oh nine.
I started at the beginning.
I started in February,
sorry.
Oh No.
Yeah,
that's when this started to,
this started in no nine too,
but I started after you,
I think I started you and first woman.
I started it,
I was doing it on a Ustream.
Brian and I were just to sit in front of a,
just the laptop,
just fucking around.
It wasn't,
the idea wasn't to do a podcast.
The idea was just to fuck around on Ustream.
Then as we started doing it was like,
wow,
this is like,
and then,
but doing yours.
I was like,
Ooh.
Adam's got like a whole garage.
Like,
look at this.
He's got a cool setup.
And then,
um,
Anthony [inaudible] from opie and Anthony,
he's got some crazy fucking set up in his basement.
He was like the big inspiration because he had a green screen and a full studio
with production cameras.
Just a lot of money in a single guy and Lexa drink.
So he was like,
fuck this.
Let's just build a studio in the basement.
So he built like a full,
which now he uses,
cause when he got fired from opie and Anthony,
he just set up and went online with it and now he has his full online thing with
the green screen behind him.
He shows images and videos
and all kinds of crazy shit.
And then we'll just,
uh,
I just did,
but I just called into a show last,
uh,
last week,
but I just did a Opie's show.
I've just in New York going fucking running in a circle.
Jesus Christ,
man,
you,
uh,
you had that lawsuit.
I don't know how much you want to talk about this if at all.
But you had that lawsuit with the dude that you started out with.
That all got settled.
That's all done now.
Yup.
It's all a year full of lawsuits.
Had the,
had that had the Pan Turtle,
the patent thing.
It was Jesus Christ that wind up costing you money.
The patent troll thing.
I know we raised some money for that,
but how did that work out?
Um,
the,
the bill was over 500 grand.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Oh my God.
Explain what the lawsuit was about cause you if people want to pull their
fucking hair out in traffic,
this is so,
it's so crazy that someone could actually pull you into court for this.
Well not only pull you into court but pull you into their court in eastern
Texas.
Yeah.
Where nobody has a podcast and nobody even knows what it is.
It's just a nice place to do business for these guys.
For those guys because of they have creepy laws.
Well they have judges,
they have relationships and you know,
first off when you just step back and you look at the entire picture,
who,
who are the judges?
Judges aren't,
you know,
x fireman,
x podcasters,
you know,
they're not carpenters,
they're lawyers.
The judges were lawyers and then the congressmen were judges and lawyers and the
senators were judges and lawyers.
There's a little good old boys club going on and it's going on in Washington d
scene.
It's going on and,
and all the places that the tentacles reach out to and it's not there to upset
their own apple cart.
You know what I mean?
Like in terms of reform and rules and righting a wrong and all that kind of
stuff.
How much you want to piss off the guy,
you're going to cut the country club with this.
You'll see him at the country club on Saturday.
You know,
it's like,
it's,
you know what it is?
It's like divorce attorneys,
divorce attorneys.
You Think,
oh,
it's your side and his side and they're battling.
And she said,
and she said,
not the attorneys.
They love it.
They're both,
they're basically the relationship.
It's like,
it's like saying,
you know the guys walking through the park with the stick and the nail in the
end of it,
picking up garbage,
picking up trash.
That guy must really hate litters.
And it's like,
no,
he doesn't.
That's,
that's how he has a job.
The attorneys are the ones that all end up just at the end.
I mean,
I've not been divorced,
but I've certainly heard enough,
and I talked to Dr Drew's not been divorced,
but he's heard enough and it's like at the end,
the people that win are both side's attorneys.
They just,
they just keep going until everything's cleaned out and they do it on purpose.
They drag things out.
It's symbiotic.
And they have the,
the pilot fish and the shark or whatever.
You know,
you think,
oh,
this guy,
this attorney hates this other turn.
No,
he tells him that's how he gets rich.
Well,
not only that,
if you're a person who's getting divorced,
understand this.
If you're going to go through mediation or whatever,
even if you get along well with your ex wife and you guys are both like,
look,
we love each other,
but this is not working out.
Let's just break up.
The attorneys will try to get your wife to ask for some really unreasonable shit
so that you can settle on some reasonable shit.
And so you're going to get angry at her unreasonable shit.
Like,
no,
you can't have my fucking collection of,
you know,
whatever.
You know,
like I know like sugar,
Shane Mosley had to give up his fucking championship belt.
He understand that he lost his fucking championship belt to a girl that he used
to have naked hugs with.
You know,
they used to get together and they used to touch each other and make each other
feel good.
So the judge decided,
well,
you know what,
you need to give up that belt that you got punched in the head for,
to this woman that used to touch you.
I would have gone like Jake lamata before he went to the pawn.
Chapeau picked out everything out of that belt.
This her fanny pack was shit any fucking thing to a tree and shot holes in it
until it was worthless.
Well,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
you know how all this shit starts,
all that.
I think all this shit starts like this.
You know,
you say,
look,
let's just as focused on the kids.
Let's focus on what's fair.
Mommy,
daddy shouldn't be arguing.
Let's not give all the money to the attorneys.
We're both reasonable people.
And then at some point,
your ex wife has some country friend who's been through a divorce says,
you should just talk to my guy.
Just talked to my guy.
And then your ex wife says,
you know what?
I talked to Joe or I talked to Adam.
We're just going to handle this and try to be reasonable about it and she'll go,
you don't understand.
You could be burned.
You're going to need to be just meet with him.
I'm just saying,
just meet with him.
Just just meet with the guy.
That's all I'm saying.
Just talk to the guy.
Next thing you know,
she's sitting in an office in century city.
This guy of course just sees a big old slab of bacon come in his way and he's
like,
oh listen,
he says this and he says that,
but what about 10 years from now or here?
You know,
he could agree to do this,
but if he just agrees to it and you guys just have a handshake,
he pulled the plug the next day on child support and what bubba alimony,
Buh Buh,
Buh.
And you worked real hard.
And then next thing you know she's got an attorney.
Now it's time to lawyer up and now it's time for these two to see how much
fucking money they can make before you guys go your separate ways.
Phil Hartman before his wife shot him and then kill herself was going through
this.
And uh,
we had a conversation about it where the,
he had a really bad relationship with his wife real bad.
Like she would insult them in public.
Like they would be at a party and she wanted a shot him the one who shot him.
Yeah.
Well I did that math.
Yeah,
I did the,
I did.
There was a little friction between the two,
some of that,
a little bit of an issue cause she killed him in his sleep,
shot him in the head while I was sleeping.
He said take cough syrup,
cough syrup and conk out cause we just so stressed out.
And he had just,
apparently the story was that he had finally told her that it was,
this is it,
this is how I'm going to pull the trigger I'm getting out of here.
Right.
And then she shot him when he was sleeping.
Um,
but when he was talking about it,
I go,
I was the one who is trying to tell him to get divorced a long time ago.
Like he had gone through these breakups where he'd moved out and then move back
in and you know,
they'd fight like cats and dogs and like,
fuck this,
I'm done.
And uh,
and you know,
a few people were saying,
you know,
you should try to work it out.
And I was like,
man,
you got to get,
she's evil.
Like this lady's crazy.
You can't fix crazy.
No,
you can't fix crazy and you can't fix that broken actress thing.
Do you know the,
the type of person that desperately wants to be famous?
And then they're medicated.
So she was on Zoloft.
And then on top of the Zoloft,
she's doing cocaine,
which literally makes you psychotic.
They want a settlement through Zoloft.
The family want to settlement.
Oh,
Raylea Zoloft apparently,
you know,
obviously I'm talking about in my ass.
I'm not a doctor,
I'm not a scientist.
But the,
the,
the word from people that have taken it is that if you take Zoloft and you mix
it with some other chemicals,
you can just lose your fucking marbles.
And one of the big ones is cocaine.
If you do Zoloft and cocaine together,
you're just off the rails.
Fucking crazy.
And that's when she shot him and then wound up shooting herself.
But when I was talking to him about it,
I was like,
man,
just get out.
Just give her half.
Fuck it man.
You're going to make more money.
And he goes,
that's not half.
He goes,
it's a fucking third.
He goes to third,
goes to the lawyers,
right.
Those two thirds you give to them,
a lawyer,
a third,
the wife gets it.
It's a fucking third to the lawyers.
And he was going,
he was going crazy,
but it's a fucking scam.
Like you could see his eyes were red,
his face was sweaty.
And he was just thinking about all the years that this guy,
I mean,
he didn't make it like really make it.
I don't think he got on Saturday night live until he was in his late thirties.
He was a graphic artist.
Yeah,
he was on peewee's playhouse.
Peewees you know that TV show that he had and he wrote peewee's big adventure,
who's one of the writers of that.
And Yeah,
did some albums for like some rock bands and the well just to,
um,
not to,
you know,
pull the conversation away from people that are dead or missing.
Where skippy by the way did you find him?
Um,
so
the,
the pod cast community along,
especially with guys like Joe got together and we stood up to these guys because
they know how much litigation
costs.
The problem with the country we're living in is everybody has this thing where
they go just set,
you know,
like I've had people who bought a house for me 10 years ago and are like,
uh,
hey man,
there's a crack in the foundation and we need 25 grand.
And you're like,
no,
what are you talking about?
And the,
and then at some point some lawyers gonna say to you,
it's a lot cheaper just to give him,
you know,
probably come down to 17,
five to skim the money.
It's going to be a lot easier than and cheaper by the way then.
And by the way,
do you have the time to go down to downtown and sit in the,
it'd be so much easier just to pay that move on and you'll go,
but what the fuck?
I mean,
I know what they're talking about.
Yeah,
I know.
I know,
But it's going to be a lot easier and a lot cheaper.
And so that's what businesses do because businesses or businesses,
they just want to make money.
They're not there to take a moral stand.
This is what I get the hell out of there.
Apple gave these pot,
these same guys at sued.
You gave them millions,
right?
I have something like that.
Yeah,
but I don't,
I think they took them to court and I think they won millions.
But either way
I was just like,
look,
it's not an option for me to cut you a check for 300 500 whatever you're asking
for that.
That's not an option.
So the only option is to stay in fight,
but the amount of money it costs to stay fight is insane.
But $500,000 no.
Over more.
Yes.
God Damn it.
But here's the deal and this is where I think your listeners and my listeners
and,
and every,
every,
every podcast,
there's listeners should be proud.
Sony and apple and whoever they're going after and they'll just go,
whoever,
whenever,
doesn't,
doesn't matter.
Paramount doesn't matter.
They don't have a microphone.
You know,
they've got,
they've got millions in the bank and they've got a big corporation,
but they don't really have a microphone.
We have a microphone.
So I use my microphone and your microphone,
Chris Hardwick's microphone.
And we all started talking and they didn't like the talk really.
And then wanted to talk to stop and to know this specifically from talking to
them,
like what did they say?
Shh.
Stop,
stop talking.
Shit.
Really cause you,
you,
they put some sort of a gag order.
Like it was part of the agreement.
Like,
well what,
what they did is they said,
what they found was,
you know,
and I've,
I've had this happen,
but it's like,
you know,
it's,
it's this weird thing where it's like,
hey man,
what's with all the shit talking?
And it's like,
hey man,
what's with all the suing?
Like they were upset talking shit while you have a little decor.
That's hilarious.
What we trying to steal money from you still while we sue you,
I have a microphone.
Explain what the lawsuit was about because it doesn't seem like people that
don't,
maybe there's some merit to this.
Maybe there's a maritime zone.
It was about something on the Internet in a serialized form.
It was that.
It was unbelievably ridiculous.
I to this day,
I couldn't really explain it other than to say if you made a playlist,
somehow they had some sort of proprietary technology.
Have a list or playlist and that's all I know.
That's amazing.
It's all I know.
So it's amazing.
We crowdfunded everything and the whole community got together and I wasn't out.
We raised enough money to pay the lawyers,
but what you'll,
you know,
the most precious commodity is time.
You know?
That's the part you'll never get back,
but don't you think you got a lot of good publicity for it?
There was a lot of interest and probably generated a lot of interest towards
your podcast.
He,
yeah,
I mean,
I imagine,
ah,
you know,
but I imagine if I have,
I got no plane crash,
I probably could get some interest too,
but it's still not the kind of thing I'm going to cross my fingers for.
Right.
I mean,
but it is,
it is the kind of thing where it's like,
yeah,
there's,
there's a side where,
okay,
you're getting out there,
you're talking about it and all that,
and that's fine.
But it's just this sort of thing where as an atheist with x amount of hours on
the planet,
reading emails from lawyers,
from eastern Texas,
it's just not on my,
you know,
getting phone calls,
I'm shooting a show for spike and the phone's ringing.
It's an update out of Texas,
you know?
It's like,
I'm trying to do this other thing.
Did you have to physically go and sit in court in Texas?
Well,
that's where,
that's what it was coming too,
but I didn't get to that point.
So you've spent $500,000 plus before you even had to get to the actual court in
Texas.
If you get to the actual court,
it's probably between one,
two and one five.
Fuck is wrong with this world a lot.
Where is that?
Where's that money going?
Look,
it's a conversation about a fucking serialized podcast.
The first 50 grand went to try to get a change of venue because we're not in
Lubbock or wherever the fuck it was in Texas as a first 50 grand.
Just got trying to move it to where we are.
That didn't go over very well.
Wow.
So you get through that,
then you get sued by your ex partner,
your ex friend or however that works,
whatever designation you want to give him.
Um,
how much do you hate the law right now?
Where are you an anarchist now?
You were going to go to the other side.
No,
but I've,
I've,
I,
I've realized that
I was thinking about it and I thought,
you know,
the,
the amount of,
of businesses,
you know,
let's,
let's just pick a,
pick a time.
1952,
the average business that was semi successful,
or the average person that was semi successful,
how often do they get sued versus 2015 I don't think there's such a thing is
being successful in business or,
or as a personality and not having people coming after you.
Now I don't think,
you know how many,
I'm sure Kanye West is 13 lawsuits going simultaneously along,
uh,
along with,
um,
Chris Brown and whoever else.
I don't think a lot of them don't make the light of day,
but I just think there's no such thing as being Pepsi or Coca Cola or Beatrice
or Nabisco.
They probably have 47 to 147 lawsuits going all year every year.
So this is like underlying almost economy of people suing to get the settlements
like the,
you know,
the UFC is going through that right now.
[inaudible] class action lawsuits,
several,
four of them at the same time.
X fighters.
Well,
most of them fighters that weren't that successful,
like weren't,
weren't like championship caliber or you know,
got to a point in their career where they realized,
you know,
hey,
I'm not really ever going to get rich off of this and then start suing and
became a part of this class action lawsuit.
Four of them that are going on
La.
It,
it,
look,
it's,
there's a bigger ECE.
It's all,
it's all trickled down
in the,
in this sense,
I've always said there was a time in this country when,
if you saw a guy driving a brand new Cadillac and you know the,
that father and son were walking down the street and here comes Mr. Johnson,
his big black Cadillac going up to the top of the hill.
There was a time when the father would look at the sun and say,
you study hard.
You work hard,
you get it done.
And one day you can have big shiny Cadillac and live up at the top of the hill.
Now smash cut to 2015 the sun's looking at the dad going,
what the fuck does he have that Cadillac?
And we're driving a III Zuzu trooper.
This is bullshit.
Let's go throw a rocket.
That guy's Cadillac or let's go see what we can get from Mr. Johnson C.
There's tea,
there's a mentality of you and I have the mentality of,
and,
and it's what this country was basically settled on,
which is go get some for yourself.
We have a larger and larger group looking around going,
wait a minute,
what are they doing and can I get some of what they got?
You know,
this whole country is,
but there's a whole mentality.
I mean,
it,
it's,
it's trickling down from the government.
It's,
it's not,
it's a sort of a slow poisoning.
You know,
it's,
it's sort of,
you know,
income inequality.
Yeah.
Why does that guy need three?
Joe Rogan's got a bunch of cars.
You try them all at the same time.
You can't drive all those cars at the same time.
I go on vacation house.
You got two houses.
What?
How many?
How many bathrooms in your house?
Joe Rogan,
you used to have five.
I got rid of one,
four,
four.
How many assholes do,
how many assholes do you have a,
well,
I live with three other people.
So you call your kids and why?
But ansul they have butts.
What do you need?
All those bathrooms and cool cars for you don't need all that.
Yeah,
so,
so it should be equal.
Everybody should it out.
Well that's what people that don't have anything thing.
They think that everything should be
socialism.
Well also it's like none of your fucking business.
What I have or what I do,
there's always going to be someone above me.
There's always going to be people below me.
And by the way,
Hey Joe Rogan,
where are you going to be this weekend?
Dowse okay.
Ask Adam Carolla where he's going to be this week or this weekend.
Portland and Seattle.
Not On my sofa.
Right?
Not with a beer in my hand.
Not playing.
Not throwing.
Yeah.
Both my kids in the backyard.
So you're trying to say that people don't have things in this world.
They don't work hard.
Adam Corolla.
Do you not understand that this is a builtin inequality in our system right now
is because of capitalism.
And capitalism is the real issue here.
The people that work and pay for things,
by the way,
that's capitalism.
You fuck people that like you.
You'd go to the store and you buy food.
That's capitalism.
Work for a job.
They pay you.
That's also capitalism.
Don't say capitalism doesn't work because it's not,
that's not the issue.
Just because you're not successful,
it doesn't mean that capitalism is,
well,
they do this shit.
They go cronyism.
They go,
oh,
you don't think that guy who's
humping dry wall on a construction site.
You don't say he's not working hard.
And I'm like,
yeah,
he's working hard.
Everybody historically has worked hard,
but he's not working smart.
He's not doing what he's got to do to get the extra car
I have because I used to carry the drywall.
Yeah,
I did.
Now,
now I don't,
and by the way,
he doesn't have to do that.
He could do other things.
If you,
if you think that job is too hard,
you don't have to do it.
Nobody is forcing you to do it.
And if you do do it temporarily and you don't enjoy the hard labor,
find another way.
There's other ways to do it.
But this idea that somehow or another,
everything's supposed to be equal is fucking unbelievably ridiculous because
there's no equality.
There's no equality in this world when it comes to look.
Some people speak five languages.
You don't,
if you don't speak five languages,
you're not fucking equal.
That guy.
If that guy goes to France,
he can communicate.
There's no equality in that.
It's no like how come these French people don't just accept my language?
It doesn't work like that.
You have to work hard.
If you want to learn how to speak five fucking languages,
like the amount of effort you put in is directly proportionate to the,
the,
the reward you get out of it.
Or if you do it intelligently,
it's the right.
But what the people would say,
who we vehemently disagree with is that guy on the construction site can't get
to the next level and can't get off that construction site because his dad
carried dry wall and he's poor and he's a product of the system and he's a
product of the education around him.
And he's a product of that environment,
which may not help as obviously much better.
You know,
Dr Drew's dad was a physician and it definitely helped Dr drew become a
physician.
But my dad didn't do shit and I got more money than doctor.
True.
So what math shall we do here?
Well,
you,
you know,
people figure things out.
There's a lot of people that figure things out in this world.
They figure out a way and some people don't figure it out.
And that's the same with playing games.
Like there's some people that are really good at playing chess.
Why are they really good at playing chess?
Well,
they study it and they figure it out and they get better at it.
And then other people fucking suck at it.
But they're also playing chess,
but they're playing chess and they're not thinking ahead.
They're not focusing,
they're not concentrating.
They might be distracted while they're playing that chess life.
When it comes to capitalism,
when it comes to,
I mean for forget capitalism when it comes to trying to,
let's use that,
that phrase,
get ahead.
That they get,
it's a game.
It's a game.
And what you decide to do,
whether you decide to build houses or you decide to make paintings or you
decided to fix cars,
wherever the fuck you decide to do,
you're essentially playing a game.
The game is,
I will try to get really good at this and hopefully I'll get some money along
the way.
And if you do not play the game and you saw it,
I'm just going to stick to this whole digging thing.
And uh,
why don't have a Cadillac?
I'm not,
I'm fucking digging this thing.
I'm working all day,
but by the way,
what if first off and then the next thing they do is,
the next thing out of their mouth is,
you know,
money doesn't buy happiness,
don't ya?
It's like,
good.
Then shut the fuck up.
Have Funding Your Zuzu trooper like okay,
then why are we saying look,
you have a family.
You know,
when I was poor,
I fucked hot chicks.
Did you really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Well not supermodels and you know,
there were little uh,
refractory periods would go on sometimes months on end.
But yeah,
I drank beer,
I fucked,
I ate out.
I had fun when you were poor.
Yeah.
I always had a different kind of fun.
It was light enough children back then to know it's like get in,
are kind of fun.
Was
getting the back of a F-150 pickup.
We're going to Baja and we're going to buy some roadside fireworks and shoot
them off throughout the back of the pickup truck and camp on the beach and surf
naked and you know,
that could start a bonfire and drink mezcal Tequila.
It didn't cost anything.
I like it,
but it was still fun.
Yeah.
I mean half the Shit I did,
you know,
I was in costs,
anything we just had fun.
Yeah.
Money does not buy happiness.
It's absolutely true.
And there's a lot of people that only focus on money and they wind up being rich
and miserable and that is a fact.
But that doesn't mean that you can't get freedom from money.
That relieves pressure and that's where people are mistaken.
This idea that it's one or the other,
it's either or.
Either you are enjoying your life as a poor person and you're happy and
wonderful and loving or you're a wealthy mizer who fucking hates his life and
lives in depression and drink himself to death or it takes pills to afford
reality.
That's not true either.
Like you what,
what,
what money does do the big thing that it did for me when I,
when I first got my first developed,
I got one of those development deals.
I got a few of those back in the day,
but I got one before the fucking,
the water ran out and uh,
all of a sudden I didn't worry about my bills.
All of a sudden,
all of a sudden I had this huge feet,
like a physical feeling of like,
like you have a different workout with a weight vest.
I like working out with weight vests.
I like doing weighted fanny pack.
That's good to my new thing.
Um,
the thing about a weight vest is you take that sucker off and he's,
ah,
he feels so good.
Yeah.
And that's how I felt when I first got my first check.
I was like,
wow,
now I know that I can pay my rent this month.
Now I know that I could go to dinner and I can order what I want to order
instead of order.
Like the cheapest thing on the menu.
Yeah.
I always tell people it doesn't,
it doesn't make you happy.
It,
what it does is it stops you from worrying about shit that makes you unhappy.
Yes.
Like,
yes.
A parking ticket would ruin my week.
I mean,
I remember getting 60 bucks out of the ATM once and leaving it into the a and
the ATM and then coming back 10 minutes later and it was gone and I was like
devastated for the entire weekend because I was at the 60 bucks.
Right,
right.
Little Shit like that just fucks you up.
You know,
there's always the,
you know when you're going out to eat and it's like,
should you,
should you order a cocktail?
She'd order glass wine.
It's going to be eight bucks.
More like don't do it.
Yeah.
He already ordered an appetizer.
Don't get greedy.
And is the thinking to the resources that are required to constantly be thinking
about your bills?
Like when I was a broke comedian,
I remember just always wondering like how it was going to pay for this.
Like,
oh,
this is coming up,
this goddamn bill is going to be on the 15th and I don't have that money.
And I got to figure out that money and making phone calls and trying to get gigs
and trying to figure out how to pay that bill.
All that goes away,
but the whole point is you never looked around and went,
who can do this for me now?
You just found a mirror and when I got to get after it a little harder.
Yeah,
you can't think like that.
That's a,
that's a,
that's a trap.
The,
don't you think when we're constantly hitting everyone over the head,
I can't stand when I hear the politicians go.
It's not a level playing field.
I'd like to tell you it was a level playing field,
but it's just not,
well,
it's not neither his life.
Can you see a beautiful woman?
We see a beautiful woman and then you see some woman with unfortunate genetics.
What the fuck did that beautiful woman did?
She earned that.
No,
this is not,
this is not even,
it's not even that good.
Some women are born with perfect bone structure and that's just,
that is just something you're going to have to deal with in this life.
You know,
I'm five foot eight.
If,
what if I was a,
what if I love playing basketball?
What if I wished I was seven feet tall?
You know,
I've met giant basketball players and I'm like fuck.
Like this is not even,
this is not,
we're not born with the same chips where the same deck of cards.
We're just not how,
by the way,
could you ever,
and then how's the government going to figure that out?
And Yeah,
you can make the school system is even as you can and you can make the law is
even as you can.
But the chick who six one who has got the,
you know,
it looks like Heidi Clume still going to have a quite quiet,
client advantage over Alex Borstein.
Yeah,
there's no way around that.
But the Alex Borstein and she's a dear friend.
I don't even know who that is.
Okay.
She does.
Let's see.
Living color.
Oh,
she's not living color.
Uh,
the Fox.
A telephonic shows.
Okay.
Yeah.
You'll know she the lowest on I get a family.
Let's go with the blossom.
Oh,
from blossom.
Who was on the Big Bang?
Maya?
My Mba.
Alec forcing is better,
but all right.
All right.
The point is,
well,
you should know she is,
you work in this business.
I know.
Barely.
The point is this because she doesn't look like Ooma Thurman.
She went to work hard developing a bunch of other skills other than looking good
on a Saturday night and now makes a nice living.
Right.
That's fine.
That's fine that it's,
it's the way it should be.
It's just let's not convince that person that they can't do anything.
Let's just say you won't be doing any runway or catalog work and,
but there's others,
but you can do a lot of voiceovers.
The what if the government comes along and figures out a way to turn everybody
into whom Thurman would if they cut and then people like,
you know,
the government should be making you look like Guma Thurman and here you are who
you are stuck with this normal body.
There's Heidi Klum running around out there.
Why isn't the government put resources to turn you into Ooma Thurman and create
jobs while they're at it this second?
By the way,
everyone becomes Ooma Thurman,
Huma Thurman becomes a five
guys would adjust.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That would be something.
Maybe it was really fun.
First six months and then she'd come down to a five.
Well,
don't you think that's going to happen anyway?
I'm 100% convinced that we're going to be able to manipulate people's bodies to
the point where within a hundred years we're going to be able to create,
you know,
whatever you want.
You could look like the thing from fantastic four,
you know they're going to be able to do things to your body.
W W people are already doing weird body modifications,
you know,
putting like bolts in their heads and cutting the tips of their fucking noses
off and weird shit just to look weird and interesting.
Tattooing their face up and get Bruce Jenner or something about the tip people
who are doing a lot of weird shit right now.
So listen,
look,
if you can go from Wheaties box to just brand new box,
you can do anything.
We can do anything because there's no greater chasm between Wheaties box and
freshly minted box and old woman.
It's very or no me,
an old woman to difference.
Not Wait.
What happened to skipping now?
Now,
now we know to know he was on some show recently.
He's out there alive.
He's still doing standup boy.
He looks like he drinks.
Look at that face.
What is skipping TV for stand up?
Um,
I don't think that's exactly what's going on.
Previously known as skippy from family ties.
When you say skipping TV that he's been skipping it for 20 years.
Making waves as a comic.
Oh,
this is like one of those weird like local newspapers bullshits down.
Even so he was a contestant on last comic standing in 2006 no,
right.
Well at least he didn't go to the woods and kill himself.
That's all.
That's all I'm saying.
It's out there.
Hoofing it.
So back to my movie Joe.
Yeah.
Back to your moving the government creating jobs for you.
Giving you a movie deal.
You,
you know why don't other people don't have a movie Adam Carolla.
Yeah.
Why do I come to make it?
Why do you get to make a movie?
Because I raised the money.
No,
no,
no.
Because your white privilege to cause your CIS gender.
White privileged shitlord out there.
I should have back when I was cleaning up garbage on the construction side,
I should have played the white privilege card.
We're still white privileged.
Even back then the other Mexicans that you were working with back then clean up
garbage.
Where are they now?
I'll tell you why they aren't where they are because they didn't have the white
privilege.
Uh,
that's right.
There weren't systems certain point.
I remember,
well it was like 1985 I was picking up garbage on a construction site in Granada
hills and helicopter landed and Donald Trump got out and he like you,
you're white.
It's amazing.
Get in here right now.
What do you think you're doing?
And we jumped in a helicopter with retractable landing gear.
By the way,
that's how you really know you've arrived.
When we flew right to Trump tower and he gave me an ascot,
and from that day on,
I didn't know about white privilege.
Evidently he'd been keeping tabs on me the whole time.
That's nice.
And that he was able to then give me the money to make road heart.
He got in with the cronies.
Yeah.
That's what happens.
People,
we all conspire together to keep white people rich.
He,
while nobody sues white people more than white people.
Right.
That's true.
Being sued by white people,
I'm sure.
Ah,
I would,
I would say,
I would say white people are the,
uh,
do the lion's share,
the white lion share of the ceiling?
Yeah.
It's a lot of white on white.
It's a little more blue collar.
We like to keep it a little more blue car.
We don't like to see our victims mostly through email.
But does the people that we're suing you?
No,
no,
no.
They just got,
they got tired.
But did you know their names?
No.
I'm a,
you know,
uh,
they didn't like you talking shit about their corporation,
their entity,
their LLC that imagine if you got some,
some actual physical dudes you could put their faces up on your website.
He,
you know,
my,
my thing was,
you know,
as soon as everybody,
not just me,
but the community sort of band together,
I was like,
I could,
as soon as they wanted me to stop,
I realized it was sorta like punching a guy in the stomach and watching wins.
You know,
like when you're sparring and go,
oh,
okay,
I get it.
He's getting that.
He's getting punched there again.
And so I doubled down.
And at a certain point they were like,
you know,
make it all go away,
Mr Wizzard.
And that was it.
But,
um,
it was,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's tough,
you know,
and,
and I understand it's,
it's,
it's sort of like,
it's a lot like going through a divorce without getting divorced.
It's just a lot of,
you know,
why am I wasting all my time with this?
You know,
why?
there's a lot,
I'll tell you what's going on sort of on a micro and macro level.
I think in this country it's essentially being punished for being successful.
Like I talked to my guys at work all the time and I go,
don't ever be successful because you'll just get the shit kicked out of here
really.
So you really tell them that I do.
And,
and,
and I do the reason joking,
obviously,
well then I go,
I know there's no chance of that,
but even if you get a wild hair up your ass,
but I mean,
you think about,
you think about the relationship,
even I'll talk to a lot of successful guy,
talk to successful guys.
Like I,
I'll,
I'll give you,
I'll give you this.
Okay.
Uh,
I go to the Mexican Lady Barber,
$12 haircuts.
I don't give a shit and she has no idea who I am.
And we always chat when she cut my hair.
And you know,
I asked her like,
how you doing?
And I know she goes to her sister's house a lot.
She's like 55,
60 years old,
but still like had sleepovers and stuff and her and her other sister go there
and they have card night and shit like that.
And uh,
whenever you find like,
especially in a just male or female,
but you start talking to that successful celebrity dude and he start talking to
him about his sister or his sisters or his brother starts scratching around a
little bit,
ask how that relationship's going.
Find out about the time that they sucked you into this business deal.
Never gave you your money back.
And by the way,
are pissed at you.
Find about that time when your sister needed a borrow,
a little whatever,
or you paid for kid's private school for like three years.
And then when you finally said,
I can't pay for it anymore,
she called you an asshole and stormed out of the room.
Like just,
just in general,
see how those relationships are going.
You know,
that's,
have a great relationship with my sister.
Get along great.
She's really,
Yeah Shit.
She's cool.
She must be doing her own shit.
She's always done her own shit.
She's just not that type.
She's just,
uh,
she's cool.
She's just down to earth.
You don't have a brother.
Nope.
I guarantee if we had a brother,
I'd beat his ass.
Yeah,
he'd be fine.
He'd be coming after you.
He'd be like,
hey man,
I got this idea for a frozen yogurt place.
Or I'd love him when we'd be great friends.
You know,
if he got his shit together,
it's all,
you know,
I have friends that have brothers and they have the worst relationship with
their brothers.
Like they fought when they were young and now they're adults and one of them was
successful and one of them's not.
It's usually like,
well that's what I'm saying is the successful one
asks the successful one how good the relationship is with the brother that's not
successful and see if it's not based on a lot of shit that the brother was
asking from them from the point when they see the guys name on the collar id
that they don't even want to pick up anymore that say no.
It's just gonna be him asking for something.
That's a weird,
the weird uncomfortable thing about certain friendships when people want to drag
you into did business deals.
But I just don't,
I don't do any of that anymore.
I did it all when I was younger.
I got into a lot of a loan.
You money situations.
You know how many people paid me back at zero zero,
zero,
zero.
No.
I always,
I always say it's hilarious.
It's like giving someone money except for when you give someone money,
at least you fucking get thanked.
This is,
I gave you some 10 grand or 50 grand and I never got thanked,
but I never got my money.
Yeah.
So it's like lose,
lose.
I'm out the money and didn't even get the thank you.
At least want to give a bum five bucks.
He goes,
God bless you.
Well people feel like they're just one deal away.
There's a friend that I have that I talked to every now and then and I called
him up and I talked to him recently and I called him up and I was like,
what's up man?
How you doing?
And I wanted it to be,
hey,
everything's good.
You know Bubba Blah,
he's just doing this and doing that.
And,
but immediately it was a fucking sales pitch for some new business that he wants
to start.
And if I get involved,
we're going to make this amount of money and it can't go wrong cause it's this
and that.
And I mean this guy has just ear beating the fuck out of me for like five
minutes on the phone.
I go,
dude,
I'm not getting involved in anything where you don't even have to get involved.
You have a little,
a little,
a little Whoa,
nope,
I'm not doing it.
I go,
listen man,
I'm fucking crazy busy.
I'm not getting it.
I just wanted to call it to say,
hi.
Look,
I'm telling me you barely,
you don't even have to know about this.
I go,
I'll know.
I'll know and it will fuck with my head and I'll know that it's out there,
but listen,
you're going to be making money free money.
It's easy.
I'm going to do all the work.
Do you do stop.
Stop.
Okay.
I gotta go.
I'll give you a fuck.
I'll give you a perfect concrete example.
Literally a concrete example.
If you buy and I did a warehouse and anywhere near your old neighborhood,
your phone will start to rank like guy.
Hey Man,
I got a Catamaran boat and I'm going through a pretty bad divorce right now to
buy it.
Oh No,
I just need to start.
Can I just put it in a parking lot for just a couple of days or maybe a couple
of weeks?
I don't know.
I'm just,
I'm staying over at the oakwoods right now and there's no place to park it and
then the phone will ring again.
It'll be another one of your friends.
Listen,
I got a new pickup truck but the old one,
it's got the Denver boot on it so I can't really drive it,
but I'm still making payments on it.
Could I just,
I could flat,
I could flatbed it over to the warehouse,
but I'm just looking for a place.
I mean I'm going to get to Denver,
booed off and then I'm going to sell it back to the,
your warehouse will immediately fill up with everyone's shit because you got the
warehouse and they don't,
and the warehouse is sorta the concrete metaphor for you having the position,
the name and the checkbook.
Right.
So you try it cause that's what happened.
How do you feel like that you feel like that trickles down from the government?
Like how do you feel like that trickled down from the government?
I think does she think that the government is just sort of responding to people
that don't necessarily know how to become successful?
And that's like the,
this is the desire,
the government,
like this idea that the government creates jobs,
the government is creating jobs.
Like what does that mean?
I don't know.
What I'm saying is,
is I don't think that the Gov,
I don't think that it trickles down,
you know,
directly from the government.
What I'm saying is,
is first off there's a mentality and the message should be pick yourself up by
your own fucking boot bootstraps.
That's what this whole country's been about.
Everybody has a story about a grandparent coming over here with three nickels in
his pocket working hard and getting his shit together.
So that should be the message.
Number one,
not well the playing field's not level and there's a wealth,
wealth and income in,
you know,
fuck that.
So the first office,
the message gets shit together and work hard.
You'll be fine.
It doesn't matter what your ethnicity is,
doesn't matter what your religion is,
doesn't matter what your background is.
Just put it together and work hard and you know you're going to be working
harder than Heidi Klum.
But English wasn't her first language either.
She figured it out along the way.
Now she figured out how to make millions of dollars.
But first off,
the the message from the government should be that.
The second thing that's more direct that the government could do is let's not
make it so easy for everyone to sue anyone or take anything.
I mean,
I'll give you a,
for instance,
if you have a house and you're renting it out and some guy moves in and just
decides to stop paying his rent,
it's good luck getting the money from him.
You'd good luck to you.
Good luck getting them out of your house.
So it takes a long time.
Right?
So the government could definitely help in that department.
That's your parcel of land that you pay taxes on.
This guy stopped paying you,
but they're siding with him.
Well sometimes people just move into people's houses and changed the locks and
squat and they say it's their house that's,
that's even worse.
And what the government is quietly saying is chose got his own house with,
used to have five toilets,
now he's got four,
she's got a couple of Nice cars up there.
Does he really need the,
I mean he's doing out Ryan,
isn't he?
As long as he's paying taxes on that other house,
there's really nothing we're going to,
is that what I'm saying?
Or is it,
or they're saying,
look,
we're so fucking overwhelmed with all sorts of other shit.
We're just going to let the lawyer sort this out.
And the lawyers being the predatory concept,
they are say look,
this is what I got a lot of money to be made and keeping this conflict going.
Cause that's what pays lawyers off conflict.
The more conflict they can somehow or another right down in books,
the more they can make it easier to sort of manipulate clauses and sue people
for things like a serialized podcast on the Internet.
Well not only that but all the stuff.
I mean think about just the f you just take your car.
Every new car you buy has a bunch of warning stickers that are,
you know,
hot glued to the sun visor,
bunch of buzzers and backup things and a bunch of,
you know,
deactivate the airbag buttons in a,
but how much does that add to the average price of a car?
How much to the average flight is added to the ticket for just all the shit that
all the insurance that the airline has to cover or that the car manufacturer has
to cover or all the shit that's going to get people sued.
Think about just how much cheaper everything would be if everyone wasn't
completely lawyered up and completely trying to save themselves and,
and,
and think about all the stupid conversations and all the paperwork and,
and how we've completely lost our humanity.
You know,
when the,
the warehouse that I do my podcast from,
when I bought that warehouse,
there was a guy in it and he sold flooring and I bought it,
but he had like nine,
10 months left on his lease.
And I said to him,
like,
if you just bought a new warehouse and you're thinking,
Hey,
I'd like to move.
It turns out my friends moved all their shit in,
but I'd like to move some of my shit in or make a studio or something like that.
But a guy had Elise for like nine months.
So I talked to the guy and the guy said,
well you know I am thinking about,
I am kind of looking for another place.
I'm thinking about buying a place.
And I said,
well as soon as you can find that place,
tell me,
cause I'm anxious to get in here with my boys and get going and start building
this place out.
And about three months later,
he's like,
I found another place.
And I said,
fine,
consider yourself out of your lease and have fun.
And he said,
I'll be out by the 30th I said,
absolutely.
And he said,
I need you to sign this piece of paper.
And I said,
what?
What piece of paper?
And he said,
the piece of paper that's releasing me from this,
from my lease.
And I said,
we don't need a piece of paper.
I just looked in the eye and told you you can leave and when you're ready to
leave you tell me.
And that's my word.
And he said,
yeah,
but signed the paper.
I should.
What do we need to pay for four?
We're two adults.
And I just told you one adult to another,
I can't wait to get in here.
I'm not going to let you.
It's not like you're going to leave and then I'm going to sue you for the next
four months that you didn't.
I'm not that guy.
I'm the one that told you you could leave.
And I shook your hand and you can leave.
And he said,
you need to sign this release.
And I said,
I'll tell you what,
I'm not going to sign a release.
So you can either take my word as a man or you can just stay here for another
four months,
but I'm not signing a release.
Wow.
And the guy said,
fine.
He just split.
Whoa.
But I'd like to,
I'd like to get,
what legally could have happened is I could have been many of the Douche bags
I've dealt with and I could have taken over the warehouse and then went and
sentence sent this guy a letter and said,
hey man,
you still have five months left on your lease and it's 3,300 or whatever.
That's a 16,000,
$500.
If we got to go to court,
this is going to get expensive.
You know what,
I'll settle for 10
and his lawyer probably would have said,
you didn't get him to sign a release.
What are you an Emba Saul?
You know what,
just give him the 10.
It's going to be a lot cheaper than paying me and going to court.
Well,
what about okay to play devil's advocate or the,
you know,
the argument against it?
Like what about things like,
you know,
the serious situation,
I believe it was Chevrolet had,
um,
some ignition issues that they knew about where cars were cutting out and it
caused a bunch of deaths and a lot of people were aware of issue,
but they knew that a recall would be incredibly expensive and they drag their
heels and they didn't do anything about it for a long time and now it's such,
just a fucking complete disaster and they're getting sued like crazy.
What about that kind of situation?
Like it's kind of important to have wars.
I mean,
yeah,
obviously the balance,
it's like,
do you have an army?
Yes.
Do you invade Canada?
No.
Do you have police?
Yes.
Do they shoot every person darker than them walking down the sidewalk?
No.
Do you have lawyers?
Yes.
Do you have shitloads of lawyers that are suing everyone?
All the time?
No.
Like so there's,
you know the balance.
There's reasons to sue.
Yeah.
You,
you know the,
uh,
Ford Pinto,
I had two of my best friends died about three miles from here in a pinto station
wagon that was in an accident and burst into flames.
Yeah.
Does the classic story that we had all heard?
You actually knew people like
Robert [inaudible] from way back,
fuck going to Csun,
God damn car pooling together crazy like 18,
just rear ended,
two cars banged up next to him,
like couldn't get out.
The whole car just went up.
Fuck.
Yup.
It's crazy.
Right?
He always wonder like,
what,
what would have those guys gone on to,
what could they have done?
And it's also weird that even though they died when they were 18,
they're still always my age,
whatever age I am.
Which is a weird thing.
It,
it,
it was in,
and it's one of those,
in that case,
there needed to be lawyers and Ford knew about it.
And for dot,
you know,
let Robert and Lenny died,
it'll be cheaper than recalling,
you know,
2.7 million units
or whatever whenever it was.
And outfitting them.
Yeah.
There's a balance.
Right.
And I,
I,
I agree with you that there's definitely,
uh,
the,
the mentality of going after successful people and you know,
but obviously there's some successful people that are cons and there's some
successful people that have gotten there by ripping people off or by using slave
labor in third world countries and charging them pennies on the dollar or two
things that could have been done in America with a reasonable wage.
There's a balance to all of it.
And it's,
uh,
for,
for people that are listening to this,
that are trying to form their own identity and carved their own path,
the key is to not concentrate on other people and go why them?
The key is to look at your own self and go,
what do I want to do and how do I get there?
Right?
Because
you could be Heidi Clume or Donald Trump,
or you could be Robert and Lenny who never saw their 19th birthday.
I'm guessing you're somewhere in between.
So if you're somewhere in between,
you're just joined a huge pool called America and it's time to get to work,
get to work pitches,
get to work,
and try to be happy along the way.
Getting hurt.
You're out of time,
man.
You only have like 90 minutes,
right?
You've got to pull.
Yeah,
I've had a crazy go to [inaudible] dot com hit the banner.
I'm going to watch it this weekend.
I've hear great things about it.
I read a great review about it.
Well,
Joe promised me this.
If you see it,
you like it and you identify with it.
Next podcasts,
say how much he loved.
I will absolutely 100% do that.
I'm Corolla,
ladies and gentlemen,
triumphant victor over podcast suing cons of America.
That's it.
Alright,
listen to the Adam Carolla podcast.
There's about a thousand of them,
uh,
various subjects and even fucking one with Dennis Miller.
Now you're doing a podcast one.
He does too much.
He makes me look like a lazy bitch.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
Adam Carolla.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Okay.